belleville l'autre quartier chinois
parisien c'est ici dans ces appartements
que les policiers des renseignements
généraux ont levé le voile sur une bien
triste réalité celle des clandestins
chinois souvent obligés de se faire
soigner par de faux médecin escroc aux
pratiques d'un autre siècle
en tout six cabinets démanteler
gynécologue acupuncteur pour talbot
logist des médecins chinois dont les
diplômes ne sont absolument pas reconnu
en france
les clandestins viennent souvent des
campagnes chinoises ou ses soins de
fortune sont courants ils ont l'habitude
d'utiliser donc médecine chinoise
traditionnelle et fonctionnelle dans les
campagnes c'est comme si nous dans
l'ancien temps vous avez des rebouteux
il y avait des royals encore l'ancien
les avortements pratiqués à plus de dix
semaines avec des aiguilles de 40 cm
aiguille 16 ans comme de grosses
quantités de médicaments importés
illégalement de chine
aujourd'hui quatre animateurs de ces
cabinets médicaux sont toujours en garde
à vue